alors les fonctions ce qui s'est passé
c'est tout à l'heure ils étaient un
petit peu arrogants pendant sa rubrique
il a critiqué la régie il a critiqué il
arrive donc la régie s'est un peu vengé
et puis je trouve que c'est bien je sais
pas ce qui est plus humiliant le parka
ou je ne sais pas c'est tout je crois on
va vous voulez parler peut-être faute
grave
j'aime la régie nous sommes une grande
famille vous m
non mais sachez bien trop que la régie
ne vous en veut pas et vous pardonne par
contre juste pour l'exemple vous serez
dans le décor jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission
j'imagine ce que vous devez penser y en
a une qui rompt sapin de noël l'autre
qui est beau garçon
mais sinon tout va bien
vous